die groko hat beschlossen den
lieferstopp für deutsche rüstungsgüter
nach saudi arabien um weitere sechs
monate zu verlängern
mit sich hintertüren viele
unionspolitiker finden dass trotzdem
falsch sie sagen dadurch könnten
arbeitsplätze in der deutschen
rüstungsindustrie verloren geht
ja genau wer diese krise wird ja auch
immer mit jobabbau gedroht ein klassiker
in der politischen auseinandersetzung
und eine neue rubrik für nicos rod
cousens kukksi.de politik blasen wollte
arbeitsplätze
[Musik]
hallo verfolgt man die debatten in
unseren medien so ist der arbeitsplatz
die am meisten bedrohte spezies unserer
zeit alles was schönes gefährdet
arbeitsplätze freiheit gesundheit
arbeitnehmerrechte mindestlohn eine
intakte natur oder einfach nur das irre
bedürfnis deutscher innenstadtbewohner
regelmäßig zu arten es vielen gar nicht
bewusst aber wenn demnächst
arbeitsplätze in der autoindustrie
wegfallen dann liegt das auch an unsere
egoistischen gier nach atemluft ich
frage mich manchmal warum das
arbeitsplatzargument so oft ins feld
geführt wird ich glaube weil
arbeitsplätze in der regel mehr rechte
haben als menschen beispiel
das kommt ein beispiel jeder
arbeitsplatz bekommt einen menschen aber
nicht jeder mensch bekommen den
arbeitsplatz und offensichtlich sind
auch nicht alle arbeitsplätze gleich
schützenswert egal was du machst du
gefährt ist arbeitsplätze als politiker
stuttgart 21 zu bauen gefährdet
arbeitsplätze in der angrenzenden park
verwaltung strafverfolgung von deutschen
steuerhinterziehern gefährdet
arbeitsplätze in der schweiz fortschritt
toleranz oder die verfolgung von
pädophilen gefährden ganz allgemein paar
arbeitsplätze in der katholischen kirche
in meiner heimatstadt hamburg wird immer
argumentiert dass die elbe wegen der
arbeitsplätze im hafen vertieft werden
müsse ich weiß es ist ein verrückter
gedanke aber vielleicht wäre es von
anfang an cleverer gewesen ein hafen
direkt am meer zu bauen nicht 100
kilometer davon entfernt aber bei
arbeitsplätzen geht es gar nicht um
logik um richtige oder falsche
entscheidung es geht um arbeitsplätze
die europäischen agrarsubventionen
gefährden arbeitsplätze in afrikanischen
landwirtschaft die menschenrechte
gefährden arbeitsplätze in der deutschen
rüstungsindustrie arbeitsplätze sind
immer das totschlagargument vor allem in
der rüstungsindustrie daher kommt das
wort totschlagargument
die rüstungsindustrie zeigt sich immer
ratlos was wir haben keine ideen wie wir
sonst unser geld verdienen sollen als
mit dem bau von panzern wir können gar
nichts anderes bauen oder haben sie
schon mal von einer firma gehört die was
anderes baut als panzer wir nicht kurz
gesagt wir leben in einer gesellschaft
in der deutsche arbeitsplätze eben mehr
zählen als menschen leben woanders
ich hoffe er findet diese überlegung gut
und sinnvoll
ihr seid in der verantwortung wenn ihr
mich nicht gut findet dann gefährdet das
langfristig nämlich auch einen
arbeitsplatz oder
[Applaus]
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße